[Music]
[Applause]
ain't no gra that hold my
body ain't no
gra hold my
down in
hold my
body in the r that hold my body
[Music]
[Applause]
down when I hear that trumpet
sound rise up under the
ground
[Applause]
my that oh my
[Music]
[Applause]
look where down the
river what do you think I
see see an
[Music]
angel hold this body
down
a that hold my body down
[Applause]
look down
Gabriel put your feet
on want
[Applause]
[Music]
you
my
[Music]
[Applause]
he
will meet me Jesus meet me in the
middle These Wings don't kill me I will
meet
you a
no hold this body
down
ain't
meet me mother and father me me down by
the
river know that I'll be there when
I hold this
[Music]
body hold my
[Applause]
down
hold my body
in hold
[Music]
my